[Music]
all right I'm going to tell you a little
bit about native web animations so
animation without libraries my name is
Lizzie
I'm live in hard on Twitter and
listening hook dot info as my website if
you wanna check it out
this this talk used to be a three hours
workshop so I cut it down to different
topics so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna do it a little bit interactive I
have four different topics which is CSS
transitions and CSS animation
performance well she says custom
properties and the web animations API
and we're gonna we're gonna pick two so
I'm gonna ask you to raise your hands
you can raise your hands twice for two
topics you're interested in and then the
one with the most interest we're gonna
we're gonna do because we can't do it
all but you can come to me afterwards
and I can tell you more about everything
you want to know all right so if you
wanna hear something about CSS
transitions and CSS animations this one
raise your hands all right if you want
to hear something about animation
performance CSS custom properties the
web animations API alright so I think it
was performance and the web animations
API so all right so we're gonna start
with performance when we do animation
the most important property to use is
the transform property there's four
things the browser can really animate
really cheaply and that's position scale
rotation
pasady and so position scale rotation
you can do them all with CSS transforms
and opacity is just CSS opacity yeah and
you use them in CSS transform property
mostly the transform property can do can
do a lot of things you can translate
things so you can move them left to
right up and down on the XY axis and
also in a 3d space with translate set
you can rotate things on different axis
on the set axis on the x axis and the y
axis so you can also do 3d rotate you
can scale things up and down then you
can skew things
yeah you can also rotate on different
axes CSS reference is really useful the
link on the bottom to like look at what
transform can do and how to use two
different the different properties
because some of them use degrees some
just use numbers between 0 and 1 some
use pixels so it's all different
depending on what you're using and in
combination with transform the
transformer richness it really important
it tells your animation from which point
it should start so if it should be
reaching from the center from the top
left from the bottom right it looks like
the like the following so if it's from
the center it's gonna transform like
that then you can also have it outside
of the object so you can rotate for
example around the circle or you could
just have it on the top left or on the
bottom right wherever you need it to
original so what happens when we change
something this is really important to to
know to realize how does the browser
paint a website what changes you can
make and how they influence the painting
so first your Chavez script is evaluated
then we
then the browser is gonna recalculate
your Styles he's gonna see how much
space does every element need where does
it go this is often when you do um left
or right up top a button with CSS also
they're layered calculations it's the
same stuff then with their paintings so
everything gets rasterized and put on
two layers so you have different layers
when your browser paint something and
you can move layers independently so if
you have a layer in the bottom you can
move it independently from from an other
layer but your browsers gonna um group
things together into layers so you don't
get too many layers because too many
layers are also on performant and in the
end we have the composite step and
that's where the browser takes advantage
of the GPU and all the layers get get
glued together to one frame and that's
what's shown to the user that happens in
the last step so all of this happens in
in one frame and so when we change
different things it's gonna influence
our performance so when we change layer
it's gonna be in the layout step so in
the second step this is when we changed
with the March and the left the top all
of these layout properties and that's
really unperformed because then the
browser needs to go to also through the
other steps after that and that's why
you don't really want to animate layout
properties because yeah it's gonna be
unperformed then with the paint step
that's when we when we change for
example the background color shadows
outlines it's more performant and then
layout but the most performant way to
animate is like I already said transform
property and that's happening on the
composite layer so transform and opacity
are the last step and then when you when
you animate those you don't need to go
through the previous steps the browser
needs to run through yeah so try to
animate are always on their composite
step this is what it looks like in your
dev tools so you can you can dip back
animations and see what's happening what
causing your animation to be slow where
where the issues are yeah and the
coloring you can also look at why it's
taking so long
also yeah like I already said a lot of
layers a bad but it's good to like
create layers for the right things so if
you animate something specifically and
you know you're gonna need an extra
layer for that it's it's good to create
layers so what creates a new layer 3d
transform always creates a new layer so
if you use trance let's see set or you
know any any kind of 3d transform
animated 2d transforms to also create
layers so if you have keyframes the anim
transforms you're gonna have those on a
separate layer being on top of
compositing layers also creates new
creates a new layer so you have to see
where where where your layers are and
you should rather animate on top layers
not on the bottom layers accelerated CSS
filters create new layers and of course
will change property creates a new layer
that's the most popular one but you have
to be aware when you create new layers
that every layer consumes memory so ya
only use them when you need them for
animation and maybe remove them and
something has stopped animating so this
is SAS mixing for like really making
sure that a new layer is created it uses
will change then it uses a transform
translate that because will change isn't
supported in all browsers so if you
really want to support all our browsers
you're gonna probably use a 3d transform
yeah and on will change because you
always create new layers with will
change you you shouldn't optimize all
the elements because you're gonna get a
lot of layers and you don't want that
and only use it if the change happens
constantly and maybe remove it when you
don't need it anymore
and yeah in some browsers it's not
supported yet so you're gonna need to
use the 3d transforms also another thing
for performance that's really important
is a function that's called
requestanimationframe in JavaScript it's
a function that the browser can optimize
so your animations will be smooth there
it will stop when you're in another tab
and it allows the CPU to chill if you go
to another website so it doesn't run
consistently if you're not even looking
at it and it's more battery friendly so
if you do consistent changes consistent
animations requestanimationframe is a
great way to to make it more performant
and you don't need to use it if you're
using the web animations API because it
does this automatically yeah and green
sock of course also uses the
requestanimationframe already and you
can use the cancel animation frame
function to end calling the
requestanimationframe function this is
what it looks like so it's a function
and then you do your your changes and in
the end you call this function again and
you start it you start calling the
requestanimationframe function by
calling request animation frame on your
function with your changes that should
happen on every frame so to summarize
this if you want to get performant
animation you should only animate
transform and opacity if possible use
will change and request animation frame
where you need them don't create too
many layers look at what layers you are
creating and animate elements on the top
layers and also inspect and test the
animations in the dev tools that's
really important and I can show you
later if someone is interested how to
use the dev tools to inspect your
animations all right that's the
performance part let's see
go to the web animations API so the web
animations API tries to combine the
advantages of CSS animation and
performance like hardware acceleration
with JavaScript so you animate
completely in Chaves script but you have
a lot of advantages you have in CSS yeah
you animate completely in JavaScript you
have more control over your animations
so doing timelines in CSS is kind of
hard if you have like more than three
staggered animations to deal with so the
web animations API tries to make this
easier and you can also pause and make
your animations faster it'sit's really
good for like dynamic and reactive
animations so when you have like mouse
movements and other more more dynamic
things you want to react to and you can
really combine it nicely with JavaScript
events because you do everything in
JavaScript you can use it in your
frameworks and you and you react
wherever you need it and yeah you get
controls and callbacks so this means
when animation is finished you get a
callback and you can pause it replay it
whatever and you can group to grouping
and timing so how does it look like the
web animations API to call it you have
you have a function on a Dom element so
every Dom element if you do document
query selector you can call on this Dom
element animate function and it has two
values so the keyframes object or a
keyframes array is the stages of the
different animations so where you start
and where you end and how your animation
behaviors and then the second part is
the timings object its how its animated
so how far fast it is how much delay it
has and other timing related things all
right so the first part the keyframes
you can either use an object or an array
if you use an object you have the CSS
property and then give it all their work
values you want to animate and if you
have an array you have an array of
objects and that's the different parts
the different frames of your animation
so that's for the first part of the
function for the second part of a
function you have a timing object it has
the duration how often you would wander
the animation if you run it forwards or
backwards if you wanted to go forwards
and back the delay the empty may and the
easing so you can use all of these are
really similar to CSS animation yet so
you can use the CSS eating's you're used
to you can use cubic pcs and also the
direction and to fill are what you use
in CSS animation so to call it you would
get an object and then you would call
that animate on this object you'd have
two keyframes at the timings so for
example this would do my object would be
scaled to zero and not visible and then
there's like zero percent and then at
100% it would be scaled to one and
visible so it would fade and scale in
and then it would take two seconds
I have an easing at run it once and to
fill for words is the fill mode this
means after the animation is finished
it's gonna stay the way it was animated
to and not go back to what it was before
then once you have an animation so once
you call this function you get back an
animation object and you can do
different things with this animation of
object so you could get the play state
in the second line if you if you're just
played it it's going to be running you
can pause your animation you can play
your animation you can answer cancel it
so may make it go away you can jump to
the end of the animation
or you could play it backwards and you
could make it faster or slower depending
on how fast your playback rate is and
you also get callbacks
you also get callbacks so also an
animation object you get callback
function so you can say animation on
finish do something or when my animation
is cancelled remove my whole Dom object
because I don't need it anymore because
the animation is done this is a little
animation I built with the web animation
API and I'm going to explain it to you
so this is the keyframes and then the
offset on every keyframe I can define an
offset and that's similar to the
percentages in CSS animation so offset
point 33 would be 33% so I can have
different parts where I want to animate
my properties then I have a timing
object and then I just call on my Dom
object I call my animation and now what
I can do is my tree is one Dom element
and I can add an event listener and then
I can take my animation object and I can
set the current time which is the time
of the animation of the Apple to zero so
it starts from the beginning and then I
replay it so I change I change the
properties I can also add an event
listener to the Apple and make it faster
here in the bottom you see that it's
that's a playback right so now the
animation is a lot faster so I can
really like dynamically change how my
animation behaves in the browser yeah
this is I think it's too small but this
is an example I did in the workshop and
here I'm just staggering
different elements after and after
another and then I can just stop the
animation restarted and it's all just
here in the JavaScript two different
keyframes you can look at it later in
copán and play around with it all right
a little bit about the web animation API
and CSS so what's the difference when
should I use the web animations API when
should I use CSS animation maybe well
CSS is great for for styling and for
static animations so if you have some
predefined animations CSS this is really
enough but if you want to like interact
with the animation if you want to react
to some JavaScript events if you want to
react to something they use it as the
web animation API might be a better
option because yeah you can change all
the things right there also transitions
and hover and focus animations so maybe
patterns or loading spinners they can
all be defined in CSS because they don't
really need to be that reactive and CSS
also is really simple and declarative so
you don't need to know like really a lot
of JavaScript to do in CSS animation so
if you want really simple animation CSS
is enough and what's cool about CSS is
also that you don't have JavaScript
blocking so if you run a lot of
JavaScript and you have all your
animations in like a JavaScript
animation library it can be that your
animations are not running because all
your Chaves script is really a ting and
if you do CSS animations you won't have
that problem the web animation API is
great for sequencing because it's built
for doing more complex animations you
get controls callbacks
you also get all your animations in your
document timeline so you can get all the
animations you have to find in your
document and you can stop them all or
replay them all or for accessibility
make them slower or
make them not play at all you also get
hardware acceleration like you get in
CSS and yeah it's gonna be natively in
your browser in the future
so all the browser's are already working
on implementing it so it's gonna be a
more advanced option on doing animation
in the browser and yeah the the web
animations API to libraries when you
should use the web animation API versus
like a big library like cheese app while
the web animation API is going to be
native so you won't need to load
anything in your browser versus
libraries can can be kind of big it
depends on which library which animation
library use but you're gonna have an
external dependency and you're gonna
need to load it so the size you don't
have any additional size in the web
animation API if you do SVG animation
which is very popular it's going to be
hard to do with the web animations API
because there's a lot of cross browser
inconsistencies in SVG and whatever
library like cheese Aptos they it's like
like a big SVG animation polyfill it
solves all these issues and that's why
you when you animate SVG you normally
choose an animation tool like cheese app
or another SVG animation library ya
browser rendering so when you use the
web animation API the browser optimizes
it because it's you're using the browser
API so the browser knows what you're
animating when you use a library often
the browser doesn't know that you're
animating this and elements and so it
can't optimize for this animation
animation and yeah it's gonna be small
because it's gonna be native this is
also interesting this is different
libraries animations without cheese
JavaScript black blocking
and if you add JavaScript blocking all
the JavaScript libraries they're gonna
be like slower and if you have a lot of
JavaScript and it's unperformed then
your animations are also not gonna run
smooth
so with web animations API on CSS
animations you don't have that problem
because you're using in browser
optimization the problem about the web
animations API is of course the
browser's support still it's in
implementation there's a really good
polyfill I'm good github and you can use
it and then it's your gonna it's like an
animation library yet you're using it's
gonna fall back to the native
implementation if it's there if it's not
there you're gonna load the polyfill and
you can use all the web animation API
things already on production sites and
the web platform tests you can look at
it to see how far the implementations
are so you can look at the different
parts of the animation and see which
browsers are already implemented which
functions
yeah that's why can I use isn't really
saying that much because different
browser already implemented different
parts of the API and you don't know if
if you just look at can I use it doesn't
mean they haven't implemented it at all
but it's still working on it it just
haven't implemented everything and just
animate is a really small animation
library that uses the web animation API
under the hood so it's it's really tiny
and it's really easy to use so you don't
have to write so many keyframes and you
get like easing x' and different stuff
these are some examples I build with the
web animation API so you get you get all
this like interaction you can reset your
animation
and then I can change I can change the
text in the back on a call back so I get
to like react to what I use it us yeah
this is with a slider so you have a
slider and then you start some some
animations yeah
so dynamic dynamic reactions to to what
the user does so that's where it's gonna
be hard to do in in CSS and that's where
you would use web animations API alright
yeah one more thing I wanted to say if
you do web animations and you want to
make your animations look better I'm
trying to level up your eating's
don't just use is in ease out but look
at different eating's there's a lot of
tools like easing studnet so you get all
these different easing Xin CSS and you
can just copy them all so here in the
bottom there are some eating's which you
can't do in CSS that's what like CSS
animation libraries do because you can
only have like a simple curve in CSS in
JavaScript you can do like bouncing
bouncing eating's which are really great
for more dynamic animations then cubic
this year from Nehru it's just great to
play around to see how you're eating
looks like and it has like in the top
you can compare different animations and
different eating's and what I also love
is a great tool is cheese app and green
6yz visualizer which is really great
because they have a lot of like more
complex easing and you can in the bottom
you can change them make them faster and
slower and when you get started with
animation this is really useful to to
try different eating's and play around
with how you how your animations behave
there
also just predefined easing zinthoss or
there's a great medium article called
crafting user interface crafting easing
curves for user interfaces which goes
more in-depth into eating's for user
interfaces all right there was it I hope
you enjoyed it the slides will be at
slides that come easily not gs uncom so
you can look through everything you can
look at the examples and copán and play
around with them and there's also the
other parts which I wasn't didn't have
the time to go through there also in
these slides so you can also look at the
other parts we didn't cover yeah that's
it thank you
[Applause]